hallo mein name ist luca meine damen und
herren ich bin eher dafür bekannt dass
ich auf youtube kompletten quality
content hochladen
daher habe ich mir heute einen test
ausgesucht der uns beantwortet wie
eigentlich sind ja das quiz wurde
erstellt von dem user namens hickel
kröte alles klar es ist menschlich und
lässt sich nicht vermeiden jeder von uns
poopst mal egal ob mann oder frau doch
längst nicht alle geben das zu oder tun
es öffentlich mit diesem kurs findest du
heraus ich habe nicht willst du du bist
deutsch erste frage zu der ernährung und
zwar was ist wo alles was mir schmeckt
ich achte sehr auf eine ausgewogene
ernährung ich mache gerade eine diät ich
bin vegetarier oder ich bin veganer ich
sage einfach jetzt alles was mir
schmeckt und das ist halt auch leider
die wahrheit heißt es pizza welcher satz
könnte von dir sein grünzeug jetzt was
für hasen ja das ist mein name jedes
böhnchen ein krönchen jede wohn einen
ton nur in der hessenschau je mehr
gemüse desto besser die gesundheit und
du bist was du isst
ich bleibe bei grünzeug ist was für
haben du bist am tisch mit deiner
familie und muss dringend pupsen was
machst du dich einfach drauflos degas
ich halte ihn zurück und hoffe dass er
wieder in meinen dann verschwindet ich
drücke den puck schnell raus und über
der kitt das geräusch mit einer puppe
als ob das wirklich leute machen ich
lasse ihnen ganz langsam entweichen so
dass ihn keiner hören kann das wirklich
also ich glaube dass man jeder aber es
gibt auch die möglichkeit mich
entschuldige mich gehe aufs clown posse
dort oder was raus muss muss raus
anschließend schiebe ich es meinem vater
zu gast bei einem guten freund über
kommt nicht der druck zu pupsen was nun
ich fuhr zu so laut wie möglich und
lache da bei euch so rechnet ja das ist
luca ich drücke meinen hintern insofern
dass er den busen langsam in weichen die
couch wird ihnen schon aufnehmen wtf
alter üblich gehe ich ins bad und päpste
dort er soll an meinem finger ziehen
dann geht's ab oder ich setze mich näher
an meinem kumpel heran und putzte ganz
leise dann sichere ich ihn unauffällig
eine stinkende luft zu ihm herüber
nee ich mach das schon so oft wie
möglich was lade ich eigentlich gerade
für ein video das musst du eigentlich
jeden tag fragen luca guckst du in der
badewanne ja soviel eben geht ich mag
global etf man nicht so gern aber
schlimm finde ich es nicht nein auf
jeden fall manchmal sogar so viel dass
nicht nur luft enden
[Musik]
ganz ehrlich ich hab jetzt vor ein paar
tagen das erste mal seit jahren wieder
gebadet und ja so viel leben geht ich
mag geblasen
du hast du guckst du in deiner nähe
stimmt es was jetzt schnell weg dreimal
tief einatmen dann ist es ich mag den
geruch einer buchse sehr gerne bleibe
also wo ich bin oder das kann nicht sein
meine puppe stinken nicht oder aber auch
egal das wird sie schon wieder verziehen
schnell weg würde ich einfach sagen
welches gefühl hast du beim pupsen es
ist die pure ehrliches poopst
erleichterung
sie können ja mal gerne auch eure
meinung zum funktionen dich und mit
darin schreiben
es ist mir grundsätzlich unangenehm auch
wenn ich alleine bin es stört mich nicht
muss halt manchmal sein ich liebe es
einen fuß in die freiheit schicken zu
können oder ist es angenehm ich sage das
mit der freiheit kurzen straße
eigentlich immer wenn du kennst wird
sich die richtig hart in die fresse du
kleiner vollidiot alles klar das ist
schön zu wissen stell dir vor du hättest
ein baby das einen krater fuhr ziellos
lässt wie reagierst du ich liebe das
und freue mich ich muss lachen und bin
ich lache ich schimpfe mit dem kind und
wechselt sofort die windel das bedarf
keiner reaktion oder ich sage zwar
nichts findet aber nicht schön nämlich
bleibt bei ich muss lachen und bin
zufrieden
richtig alle theater jetzt wird es
interessant ok meine damen und herren
das hier ca sowie werden bei wer wird
millionär auf die millionen zugeht nur
halt mit pupsen anstatt geld die stehst
mit mehreren leuten im aufzug und hass
geprüft was jedoch keiner mitbekommen zu
haben scheint was machst du jetzt gar
nichts ich schäme mich fürchterlich und
steige beim nächsten stopp aus auch wenn
ich hier gar nicht raus muss ich kann
mir ein leises lachen nicht verkneifen
und versuche die verpestete luft mit
meinen händen in die kabine zu verteilen
es ist mir unangenehm und ich schaue die
anderen nicht mehr an mich nehme
natürlich auffällig eine schiefe nase
und schaue alle anderen höchst
vorwurfsvoll an das natürlich also in
dem aufzug kurzmann ich finde andere
leute sind mittlerweile sind wir aber
schon bei der letzten frage und zwar die
wichtigste frage zum schluss was machst
du wenn du unter der bettdecke poopst
hast
ich habe einen arm und lasse den pups
dampf an meiner nase vorbei entweichen
wieso hebst du denn den arm hebt doch
einfach dein bein hochaltar ich putze
mir unter der bettdecke das stinkt weg
stinkt weg stinkt wegen putzen
es ist schlichtweg gelogen einfach jeder
furz unter der bettdecke auch wenn man
kennt man so häufig ich weiß dass ich
habe eine freundin ihr habt mir schon so
oft gesagt dass ich nachts puppe ich
krieche unter die decke und schnüffelt
den ganzen fuß etf ich bleibe still
liegen und hoffe dass der geruch nicht
zu meiner nase zieht oder ja die letzte
antwortmöglichkeit ich schüttele mit
meinen füßen den unteren teil der
bettdecke um den geruch nach unten hin
zu vertreiben das mache ich selber sehr
häufig aber ich bin gespannt was dabei
rauskommt wenn ich sage ich kriege unter
die decke und stifte den ganzen
vorzeigen wenn verschicken den später
gespannt auf die auswertung kleinem ist
ratte glückwünsche du bist ein richtiger
furz liebhaber es stört dich nicht auch
mal eine stinka loszulassen und etwas
lauter aus dem hintern tritt kommen
trotzdem kannst du dich gelegt sich
zurückhaltend und eine eigene puppe auf
andere zu schieben muss nicht sein
ja ok sorry minister pickel kröte wenn
euch das heutige video hier gefallen da
meine damen und herren anlass gerne mal
einen ich dachte jetzt die feld cool
runter aber sie hängt einfach immer noch
anlass gerne einen daumen hoch bei
diesem video hier darf also soll ich
gefallen hat das würde mich sehr freuen
wenn mikrofon und ich würde sagen die
letzten worte hat mich das trau dich vor
täglich 70.000 mal am main hat sich
zeigen
[Musik]